this [ __ ] had a blow job in here
before it came it smells like common
[ __ ] ass
wow
he's a very trained nurse and he went to
get Seafood but there was only two guys
that came out of this car
[Music]
now we got we got a little bit of a dumb
ass in our hands here okay accidental
though it's one of us
yeah it's one of us now I want to give
this guy a little credit because anybody
can make an accident but this just
happened to be a very costly one
as a valet worker oh no oh no the LA
worker and he happens to get in the car
very expensive I
think they parked with the car in the
ocean yeah
they're at no boo and [ __ ] that's like
for like six miles he's old no whoa I'm
talking I'm talking very expensive I'm
talking like one of three
why would that guy even validate
I won't even touch a car if I like that
dude oh three you better have the
supervisor dude leave that car at home
you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't valet those
[ __ ] I know that's why I always do
public talks dude you're asking for it
it's also cheap oh that thing looks
crazy Ferrari oh my gosh it's a
Batmobile we got badass girl bro damn
which Ferrari is one of three the
[ __ ] La Ferrari this car it's that
exact car this car right here and then
is is a valley inside it
oh oh so Valley's inside of right now no
no no no
hold the e-brake please just just get
out of there
all right we're gonna fast forward a
little bit no no no no no no no no no
like look how sick this is man
no no no no no no no check it out why is
it still on wait why is it rolling oh
oh my oh
you're [ __ ] stupid
oh my god oh it wasn't that bad it's not
that bad but it's costly right now but
the but the reputational damage on that
car is gonna they got insurance they got
insurance there's another angle oh my
what was that another angle almost hit
this guy too because now now collectors
are not gonna pay a premium for that
whoa you can't you can't say not that
bad for a car like that yeah with that
you you're in I was I just was expecting
it to be excusing him but in his defense
that car probably doesn't operate anyway
like nothing no no no no no no no it's
hard if I gotta stick your dick in the
thing and then what was it's
more like the valley the valley found
himself
an originally marketed price at one
million pounds Ferrari uh due to him not
knowing how to park it no it's look I've
had one job in my life when I was
younger as valet parking cars at
Gladstones all that seafood restaurant
it's a nice restaurant and that was
broke and I had no it I had no other
skills I'm a child actor [ __ ] Valet
Park cars so
ain't no joke Porsche is the [ __ ] key
so every car is a different [ __ ]
animal but don't they teach you on this
oh don't do that [ __ ] nothing bro
there's no training after I Valley Park
I was a bunch of [ __ ] bring out the
training Ferrari
hey Lou yeah you know you're you're
[ __ ] driving people's cars around
you're like [ __ ] that I would never
valet park no way any nice car any I
mean I don't like care too much about
cars anymore like you have them and then
just if you put that much value in
something like a collector's piece don't
[ __ ] valet that [ __ ] yeah you got
kids handling your [ __ ] that are [ __ ]
high or [ __ ] up or bullshitting you're
asking for it right you're asking the
weird thing too is that at least for
some places if a car is really that
valuable they tell you okay they have a
100 and you park it and you park it
that's just for those people because the
other thing with the Ferraris and I
don't know because I just play some
video games this it's paddle shifting
yeah that's weird what the [ __ ] is going
on if you don't what what the [ __ ] am I
paddle shifting this [ __ ] so he had it
on first gear yeah it was probably still
in some sort of gear that obviously or
like it got into gear but he got out of
it so it was like stopped and he got out
and then when the door closed it got in
the first gear moving forward we don't
[ __ ] know this thing because those
race car looking ones if you ever seen
their steering wheels it looks crazy
there's like 50 buttons on it like I
don't know unless the paddle shifter is
on a spot that he tried to use for
balance when he was getting in and it
clicked up oh but it looked like it
really looked like it just started
rolling again and then he tried to come
in to like put the brakes on it but he
couldn't put that's what I mean maybe
before he got in he put his hand on the
wrong thing either way the the
unfortunate event put the cranial
control took place in Monaco's lavish
Monte Carlo meters away from the world
famous Casino Square the royal blue
LaFerrari crashed after the valley made
the mistake of leaving the car in gear
after parking beside the pavement as he
waited for the owner of the hyper car so
he's bringing it back around for the
owner oh so the valley guy did mess it
up yeah so the car originally remained
stationary but began to move forward
once the car door was closed
unfortunately the car crashed into a
pair of mopeds after the valley door
closed narrowly avoiding one of the
Riders desperate valet tried to stop the
car by opening the door and getting back
into the car but his attempt was
unsuccessful
a video the incident uploaded to uh
YouTube shows the owner running over and
he's like are you [ __ ] stupid what
the [ __ ] are you doing god dude valet
who appears to be ashamed as he hangs
his head is not heard to say anything
when he exits the damaged car poor guy
when the valley came out of the car
though he looked like a mess like he
looked like a drunk man at a bar bar
mitzvah or some [ __ ] it's stressful
driving someone's nice car it's
stressful yeah what especially some nice
ass car like that you've never seen
before there's a saying that like a
[ __ ] used Camry is worth more than
like a crashed Bugatti really yeah
because like like they're like for
instance there's a camera number one car
for like 10 years well there's a Bugatti
that some some guy tried to collect some
insurance on it and fraud it and he
drove it straight into a lake and like
the value of that think about it it's
like anyone who can afford what the
depreciated value is wouldn't want it
because they could buy something better
but anyone who would want it still
couldn't afford it even at its like
lowest possible value so it's a stupid
purchase what is a person in that
bracket gonna do with the broken you got
that car man you can't you Gotta Be You
Gotta Be gangster like even the guy
crashed your car you gotta be like it's
all good [ __ ] happens yeah
I'm gonna throw it in the gutter and go
get another like you know I'm saying you
kept me out there tripping you out there
flexing dog if you out there with the
super flex and someone [ __ ] your [ __ ]
up you gotta be cool enough to be like
to the young kid or whatever this guy
makes 10.95 don't trip
[Music]
it's not one of three but it's
considered one of the Holy Trinity of
supercars alongside the McLaren P1 or
the Porsche 918 spider dude but leave it
at home he's like dude I wanted a red
one anyway so do the limited production
prior to its release the car which has
been which was sold as new for anywhere
from one to 1.2 million pounds back in
2013 is now expected to be worth between
three to five million pounds
set it himself [ __ ] goes up
that's why I'd be buying them and the
LaFerrari is one of three cars
considered to be groundbreaking because
the car boasts Hybrid Power which was uh
achieved unseen levels of performance
wow on a one out on a one one millionth
scale of this when I had my DeLorean I I
validated at the Grove and so like
because the delorean's so old that even
the key is valuable if you have the
original keys wow there's two keys one
for the ignition one for the uh
compartment behind your seat they look
totally different the a valley guy tried
to start my car with the wrong key Jam
[ __ ] it in there and he was forcing it
and then broke it off inside oh no and
there's nothing you can do you can never
get that that same exact key again
those keys on the same thing I know so
then I like I complained and then they
literally it was just shrug of the year
they were just like what well we can't
do anything you know so they don't pay
for anything no they throw you through
this they have an insurance there's an
insurance of like they'll make you sign
this thing it's called The Armenian
[ __ ] puzzle
God damn medium puzzle The Armenian
Merry-Go-Round yeah
I was at the Grove oh okay never mind
the half Korean half Armenian because
the ballet dudes are either Korean or
Armenian in an occasional Mainland
Chinese
that's true and I was battling also so
something
a Filipino Trail actor yeah yeah I would
not [ __ ] ever jump into if I was a
valet I'd rather get fired than jump
into a car I can't handle yeah because
even if you scuff that with your key and
you you barely just scratch it like you
keep which is which is kind of a strange
thing because most most companies that
handle expensive cars always try to find
a way to make you do it if you guys
notice like even if you call a tow truck
and you're driving something really nice
they'll be like all right I'm back to
truck over here and then you because
they don't wanna they don't want to be
yeah any way that they can not have the
liability what was crazy when I was when
I was valet parking cars is and I mean
it's just because after me but it's like
if you sit in someone else's life for
just that moment and you feel like one
day no no no no no no no well for rides
one thing but most of the time you know
you got glass tones before it got really
nice it was just all kinds of different
people it's like a mini you smell what
they smell like yeah you smell their
family you you sitting in what they're
sitting in and you're just like driving
like okay this person some people you
seem like this it's not a bad life some
people are like man [ __ ] this life I
have to get the [ __ ] out of this car as
fast as I smell like [ __ ] in here some
people like
I was like [ __ ] you want to be on a rich
man's hairy back yeah but it's so
strange it's like sit in their life for
like you know a minute however long it
takes to park the car this [ __ ]
had a blow job in here before it came it
smells like common [ __ ] ass
wow
he has a very trained node and he went
to get Seafood but there was only two
guys that came out of this car
one of them was my father what he gets
that you got weird fantasies
[Music]